[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
où
mais assorti ses mémoires il faut
trouver un truc ils descendent napoléon
ah bon ouais c'est vrai dit il
on a deux ouvrages un ouvrage de deux
heures 20 ce qui est un historien c'est
connu c'est le nom du soir de napoléon
non c'est une édition du 19e illustrait
la reliure et a été exécuté un peu plus
tard mais mais l'obligé à soutenir de
l'époque qui avait gravi aussi des
gravures de charles arrestation d'unique
doumbia
[Applaudissements]
pression de graillon gravé sur le bord
vraiment également un livre une
traduction de 2000 ludwig qui est un
autre allemand 1 et donc qui était
spécialisée dans les biographies donc
c'est une
un exemplaire qui a été relié qui
appartenait descendant de la
rochefoucauld qui avait un château près
de chartres c'est clément qui m'ont bien
sûr je connais tu connais les gens qui
l'ont racheté surtout avant du cheval
maintenant là bas on des attelages oui
dynamique a racheté sa la devise des
propriétaires s'étaient c'est mon
plaisir et elle figure sur le dos du
livre
[Musique]
une gravure gravure de napoléon 1er
consul ah oui d'après d'après isabelle
c'est une gravure de napoléon 1er consul
merci tu as mal à
cacher ses élèves pour nous c'est non
c'est même un peu moins cher que c'est
un retirage d'un prêt les cuivres junos
et 80 ça doit être très mince est une
région donnée dans les jardins de la
maison je crois je mangeais pas prendre
ça oui peut-être ce soit un mouvement
vers un oui
ou pour la présentation peut vous
dans un arrêt dans un papier si vous
voulez sauf ça fait un peu cadeau ça il
a fait ça
c'est ici qu'il ne l'était en ont je
viens à l'initiative l'elysée oui s'il
venait souvent faire des promenades mais
il se promenait libyennes et si oui de
régulièrement qu'est-ce qu'il a signé à
voix des éditions originales les gens se
rendent dans l'après-midi milles alors
oui il se ménageaient tous les après
midi avec des gens que pas excusez moi
allô
oui oui je suis chez le libraire en face
de la maison en train d'acheter une
gravure pour robert laffont tu m'appeler
pourquoi
non pas du tout non j'étais en train de
parler que le libraire
peut-être peut-être que je t'appelle je
t'appelle inconsciemment c'est l'amour
maintenant je t'ai appelé écoute voilà
maintenant je t'appelle sont même on
apercevoir tu vois c'est l'amour
bon je t'embrasse temps on fait le
paquet là mais ça va il n'y a pas de
souci
ah oui c'est vrai mais
bon allez je t'embrasse
non ça va non je le prends comme ça
merci beaucoup au revoir alors j'y vais
depuis ce matin mais ce problème merci à
vous et
allez ciao
c'est un prémisse
merci bon dîner la mer car c
grand manteau ensuite roman sotchi
kramer aux plantes c'est ma langue au /
ap
et
j'hésite entre
marshall au de
chamallows de parmesan et ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bonsoir oui robert laffont elles
sont au quatrième étage monsieur s'il
vous plaît merci
on fait si toi je dois lui
j y crois pas qu'on aurait dû le pousser
stéphane plus tôt
moi j'ai pas beaucoup d'appétit
de l'appétit la gourmandise tanguy non
ça c'est des mots glissés de gourmands
et des carottes non mais c'est des
cartes
vont très
vite et
avec toi
je devrais tordu le mec pana des vicieux
comme d'autres c'est le sexe
je sais c'est la bouffe mais c'est
pareil c'est plutôt les fourneaux voilà
[Applaudissements]
mais il soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez me confier vos vêtements
sans problème attends je vais laisser
des choses on est tout
simplement 50 ans à l'époque bonsoir
bonsoir savannah
fils
suivez-moi allait pas par 3i allez papa
bah oui mais je
le soutiens quand même
moi je trouve très enfants oui non mais
vraiment c'est vrai ça s est ce qu'on
sera comme ça qu'a droit devant et ça
nous fait encore du mal à acheter à toi
moi je suis vieux moi moi j'ai 56 ans et
les + plus que dix ans plus tôt
et oui vous savez la série gêne à
laisser les jeunes nantais 66 ans a eu
lieu
jeudi 4 à gérer pour une fois vous le
dites parce que plus ça se voit pas du
tout tu m'aurais dit j'ai 56 ans à
eybens on fait comme tous
j'ai lu ton livre tu sais alors j'ai
trouvé très très passionnée au moins
parce que quand français c'est on a fait
tous les deux en même temps on va faire
notre chemin ouais moi j'ai cherché la
diversité tout est à chercher diversité
dans les médias payot il vit aussi folle
que la sienne non mais non mais c'est
vrai je ne pouvais pas les autres ouais
tu vois comme un ennemi vous avez dit
heather a diminué vendredi me louis nagy
[Musique]
j'ai pas eu une jeunesse j'ai pas eu de
jeunesse parce que je me suis mariée
trop tôt et puis c'était la guerre alors
là le l'occupation et quand ça a été
fini ça a été je dis marre et j'ai
commencé mon métier mais c'était dur que
vous allez bien vous quoi 23 ans vous
avez fait votre votre maison d'édition
pourtant
il était déjà là depuis un an et c'est
sa première oeuvre
la première publication
la
vie c'est le barman du bar ont donc
maintenant cette venue au wat
c'est la boîte la plus branchée
apparaissent comme les bars a passé
toute la beauté de ta maison mais où ce
même trottoir avenue marceau fouilles
aléatoires donc même maison à thônex
maison ça reste mon père l'a font quand
même
il ya à 100 m en descendant et le
barreau c'est quoi ces édifices
maintenant n'ont cessé manioc seillière
sédières tirs hier c'est sa roue
l arrivée d arrivée des grands groupes
c'est très marrant d'ailleurs parce que
ce que vous dites c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux choses qui ont profondément changé
l'édition c'est l'arrivée des groupes
oui et les agents
la scène molson par exemple ça fait 1
c'était un événement que houellebecq est
un agent quoi ouais y'a que les éditeurs
maintenant il ne reste plus rien toi tu
es parti au bon moment comme non mais
tout y passa devant anne parce que joris
pas là vous avez des enfants quand même
incroyable yann qui a trouvé pas le coup
et l'eau et isabelle l'a trouvé le
davinci code ça va quand même tu vois
moi je serai fier que que mes enfants
fassent elles elles ont un changement de
mains elles ont pris le flair du père
c'est incroyable ça aussi c'est dans les
gènes bon papa alors merci autres enfin
un concours de barman en fait cher qu'on
fait des cocktails toutes les semaines
et on essaye de trouver le meilleur le
numéro un des 28 mètres et combien de
toi 17 18 16h20
ça fait trois jours que je sais pas où
j'ai eu trois projets eu trois
opérations du coeur mais quand on fait
le premier pont tâche était tout à fait
les premiers en 81 alors on prenait dans
la jambe et c'était pas c'est ce n'était
pas solide et on m'avait dit ça tiendra
une dizaine d'années pas plus et alors à
dix ans après j'ai été réopéré mais là
c'était affreux parce que j'ai été opéré
on a recousu ce 8 heures pour faire
tourner le changement d'étagé tout ça on
me recours mais aux soins intensifs et
là j'ai fait un infarctus et on nous
remet dans la salle d'opération et on me
ré ouvre deux ouvertes de zonage des je
commencerai mon round face entre
ces gares c'est l'année où ali zaoua là
si vous avez dit
avoir une arrière génial
avait dit un tapis de roses
quand vous avez des accidents cardiaques
et où vous avez eu comme des des
expériences ce qu'on appelle devenir des
faits je vais rien jeune j'aurais j'en
ai une j'étais à moitié réveiller parce
que j'étais dans le comme on l évasion
au réveil russe et non après dans gt
enchanteur animations lorsque
brusquement j'ai vu un arc en ciel et
puis leur camp ciel s'est transformé en
pont et sous le pont une rivière
extraordinaire de l'est fait d'hommes et
de femmes qui passent et dont on ne
voyait que les que des bustes et écoulée
qui coulait qui coulait comme ça et
entre ces il y avait une densité d'amour
extraordinaire senti la force d'un team
fortement jusqu'à prix montent englober
j'ai vu alors à ce moment-là un appel d'
amour extraordinaire et avec des
exemples en même temps deux il y avait
un visage ravagé par les pleurs etc plus
quelqu'un qui passait du fg comme ça et
élèves arrêtés ou deux ou trois paroles
apaisantes et puis sur la rive des gens
tristes de quitter nos yeux comme ça et
puis les amalgames un choix il a gagné
des gens qui étaient heureux oui et les
gens qui n'avaient pas leur histoire et
puis ce flou coulé et moi j'aime la
soirée là c'est parce qu'ils vendent ou
pour aller au paradis ou encore des
trucs comme ça je me dis vous maintenant
absolument que je sois dans les gens
heureux qui ressemble de l'amour parce
que je crois que la gueule sur la rive
sous pas dans l'éternité
il ya un truc que j'aime bien dans le
rythme des armes de l'église c'est quand
les gens se donnent la main oui ça c'est
un truc est récent et bientôt le très
beau quand j'étais petit j'allais à
l'église comme ça je me disais mais
quand même 6 6 et u à côté de ce
monsieur on partage les mêmes choses et
il reste on devrait tous s'embrasser une
fois dans le rouge est une pratique et
très très factuelle des choses je suis
pas un intellectuel mais le
christianisme s'étend de la main à
quelqu'un quand même pas obligatoirement
c'est aimez vous les uns les autres
c'est ça ta lancée à l'été les gens pour
qui on n'a pas besoin de demander la
liberté c'est le fait alors c'est vrai
que c'est
dur
[Musique]
à
enfin pas
[Musique]
ils m'ont soit
c
meta s'il vous plaît c
[Musique]
j'étais en tournée là non moi j'étais en
tournée alors lâche moi de me faire tout
démentiel presque arrivés joue une pièce
il s'appelle
jamais deux sans toi avec maurice risch
et on est moins une tournée comme
beaucoup maintenant c'est en car et tout
est là on s'est fait quand même à
toulouse dunkerque à wimille 1000 milles
10 km exactement déroulé pas de 7 heures
du matin de toulouse on est arrivé à
7h15 à dunkerque et on a joué à 8h30
donc j'ai pas bloquer les toitures c'est
vraiment sa passion
[Musique]
ça
elle m'envoie 11
pour me confier vos vêtements
chaque jour également rouler
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
très
haut
débit
de joie
je me permets remets toi non pas si tu
tiens moi c'est ma fête pour père m'a
fait le con près moi j'aime pas le t
shirt mail
rayot du lavedan
alors temps samedi quand même moi je
suis
très bien
j'ai lu monica bellucci dans le film de
blier ce matin avant que tu es des
plaidoiries donc elle sait se passera du
temps
voilà l'été les chômeurs énorme c'est
vraiment là ma main bah oui parce
qu'elle a fait ce film elle venait
d'accoucher j'imagine ah oui well
allaité pendant le film vous connaissez
caroline mon amie caroline proust mais
c'est votre vrai nom proust oui c'est
mauvais c'est vrai que c'est un pseudo
moi c'est un pseudo sermonne vous n'êtes
pas rentrer avec marcel alors le seul
lien de parenté que j'ai avec lui c'est
que je suis né le 18 novembre doit pas
marquer dix morts 19 ans très grande
comédienne alors si vous le comédien je
suis comme ils viennent voilà oui bah
oui c'est pour ça c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est rencontré avec celles censées
rencontrer parce que j'ai tourné avec
son mari clovis cornillac
c'était assez drôle quand on rencontre
parce que
je les ai rencontrés le jour où j'avais
une scène un peu chaude avec le vis tu
d'études les cochons avec le monde et
s'embrassent et quand même et où ai-je
elle est venue avec ses fils en tournage
et j'ai trouvé tout de suite extrêmement
sympathique et je dis bon ben je
vais me faire tomber donc s'est imposé à
fulham au dessus
tu toi tu irais
je suis très flatté parce que ton mon
père d'abord non seulement lille a lu
mon livre mais en plus il me tutoie je
sais pas laquelle des deux choses est la
plus flatteuse final un peu la classe
mon grand-père et non moi je me laissais
pas aidés non on s'est croisé l'autre
jour au stade absolument comme les deux
grosses et alors j'ai succédé à ses
succès est déjà passée tandis que moi
j'ai pas encore passé
ça déconne à cette grosse tête non pas
du tout
je connaissais pour qu'une des réponses
aux j'étais content parce que j'ai
trouvé sacha guitry c'était assez facile
honnêtement n'importe quel rétro et mais
après derrière je pourrais lucien
électrique ah oui là c'est plus
sophistiqués une jungle était là c'était
assez content de moi je me suis dit
quand même mais je me suis bonne idée
suite de génial qu'est ce que tu as eu
du tour au téléphone
du tout oui la règle amazon comment
s'appelait la reine des amazones faisait
du tout répond même d'y signer tu vois
c'était bien
sympa qu'il a pu
bonsoir
oui bonsoir
eh bien au quatrième étage
tessier de voir jean dutourd trouvé
cette la crosse de toi tu la trouves
mais pas quand c'est ton avis cordiale
l'ue sera je crois pas qu'ils sachent
dire le ptz est
[Musique]
inconnu vous êtes bébé
parce qu'on est tout petit au jardin
d'enfants la hausse des prix imbattables
mais sa marge brute histoire c'est pas
la seule
non pas du tout en même temps il fait
tout pour ingénieurs et gérer ses actifs
dont je parle tant de ne pas vraiment
entendu puisqu'il travaille beaucoup
d'eau qui par pas mal comme à la carte
écolo
[Musique]
ciel
j'atterris
salut ça
[Musique]
sert concessions
j'ai dû la faune
dis moi je disais ah non non j'en suis
la femme avait deux filles une qui
trouve paulo coelho et l'autre qui
trouve le davinci côte c'est pas mal
quand on est éditeur qu'est ce que tu as
préféré le coup il ou
non mais mouille toi un peu que je me
fâche avec une de mes filles mais non
c'est une autre question on te connais
tu es sincère bini la vérité répondant
je refuse de répondre et tu sais que
paulo coelho écrit ses livres près de
chez moi dans les pyrénées ça va jamais
compris pourquoi c'est tellement riche
aller s'enterrer dans cet endroit de
nerfs mais ce que je sais pas pourquoi
si tu l'état les scouts la base je ne
crois pas joyeux si je vais alors je
peux raconter l'histoire de paolo conte
c'est très belle et brigitte cutter
j'adorais cette maison d'édition avec
avec mon mari on a créé sept personnes
tous les deux ebro savais pas trop ce
qu'on allait faire et puis j'avais une
cousine germaine qui s'appelait brigitte
notre cousine germaine que j'adorais et
elle habitait barcelone et ont cherché
des souhaits a été la première à nous
donner des sous vraiment c'était elle et
elle lisait beaucoup elle faisait
beaucoup de recherche un peu spirituel
et tout ça est un jour elle m'appelle et
un petit âne je viens de lire un un
petit livre d'un auteur brésilien qui
s'appelle paulo coelho il vient d'être
publié en espagne en espagnol temps et
j'adore ce livre moi je n'ai pas
l'espagnol
des jeux donc je ne pouvais pas avoir un
avis mon fils c'est fn à l'époque
faisait des études en espagne je lui
envoie le livre
aussi il me dit maman seule idée superbe
est vraiment alors ma cousine qui habite
et personne je dis est ce que paulo
coelho puis a déjà publié en france je
ne savais rien de lui elle invite la
jambe paulo qui abîment jeune
brésilienne qui était à barcelone et
elle lui dit écoutez nous paulo coelho a
envoyé son manuscrit à quelques éditeurs
français dont robert lafont a refusé
extraordinaire tu as refusé mais non
mais parce qu'il savait pas du tout ce
qui a été travaillé chez nous est un
pari mais il n'a pas aimé kim mais on ne
les met pas au morizet l'iphone au début
et pas aux poings serrés mais pas ce
livre comme ça sans l'avoir lu
simplement parce que ma cousine et mon
fils m'avait dit que c'était un livre
merveilleux et je veux dire si j'ai pris
ce livre parce que vraiment où vous
pouvez pas savoir moi je pensais
peut-être qu'on ferait j'y croyais mais
je sais pas si on offrait dit neil moi
je me souviens de papa lisant papillon
un journal à l'aps peut-être cher dit me
va me va mais elle l'a fait voilà vous
avez fait combien 1 1 million 200
papillon du tibia en trois ans lorsque
j'avais fait radioscopie avec lui il me
dit c'est comme il était devenu honnête
comme il l'avait toujours été il me
raccompagne à l'ascenseur ou plutôt je
raccompagne à l'ascenseur et là il me
dit écoute petit
si tu as un problème un jour tu m'en
parle j'ai toujours mes groupes
mais il est épatant en revanche je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il ait écrit sa
véritable histoire et a sûrement écrit
l'histoire des autres il a créé
l'histoire des autres nice et prouver sa
non mais tu l'as fait mais d'ailleurs il
m'a compte mais il y était il écrit là
exprès une antho font une il a fait un
roman et quand il n'a envoyé il ya vait
roman dessus moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
tellement ce n'était pas du tout un
ronan que c'était un récit gmi récit et
après il m'a pas dit non
mais pour le dr vinci code part à
isabelle quand elle a pris elle a
beaucoup aimé mais elle poursuit en
faire dix mille à mille trente mille
mais elle pouvait pas s'imaginer savait
pas d'option quelque chose c'est une
famille de best-sellers tu vois moi j'ai
importé le mot pitch ton père il a
importé le mook best-seller en france
c'est à dire les best-sellers robert
laffont les belles années à la santé de
fer à votre santé robert les gens
d'estuaire
[Musique]
ici l'histoire terrible c'est avec moros
quand même j'ai jacques moros m'écrivent
pour me dire qu il va faire un livre sur
marseille
les origines de marseille
et puis rendez vous à lyon je vais à
lyon classe e
le cours de l'action française était
repliée avions même de michel herranz
michel déon travailler à l'action
française âgée de 17 ans et moi qu'ils
aient plus que josé le produit à leur
jeu
j'ai rendez vous avec mme orosz dans un
café de la place bellecour
j'étais impressionné de voir mes amis
étaient sous comme tout il était sourd
[Musique]
les brosses comment est ce maire nous
dire comment se fait-il qu'on me traite
de collaborateurs jeu et elise sont des
de ceux-ci et cetera il sort une
bordée d'un jour
entendu crier en très fort et les
germanophones en place pour place de
choses et moi je me disais mais je vais
le faire arrêter pour attentat contre
eux par un bonhomme qu'on compense
collaborateurs et de départ moi je
trouve que la maison chez les malades à
cause monarchique machine monarchiste je
pense que maurras a fait beaucoup de mal
à marcher parce que maintenant les gens
face à auxerre s'en persuader que
monarchie son extrême droite alors que
ne pas confondre monarchistes et royal
est loin mais c'est vrai que vous avez
de la chance femme je dirais de le
rencontrer parce que c'est quand même un
type qui sur le plan intellectuel a
dominé l'avant-guerre d'une façon
incroyable
[Musique]
alors j'étais petit ma graisse mais
riche
faune et ses côtés
chancel
[Musique]
alors toi patrice tu avais la table bay
a déjà tué le nom jean claude et la
chamade a dit là vous êtes là robert
à max je crois que tu es là tu vois
chance elle est ce que tu vois écrit
chancel quelques oui là anna tu veux
rester on peut rajouter un couvert n'y a
pas de problème tu veux moi c'est
[Musique]
alors ma je racontais tout à l'heure à
robert laffont m notre apostrophe ce que
maintenant on est en morceaux
d'anthologie secret commun signé mais
quand j'ai fait quand j'étais petit j'ai
fait louis 20 ans 86 je me suis retrouvé
chez pivot avec max qui défend des
robespierre et défendez je dois repasser
il y avait deux arguments qui
s'affrontaient il y avait il à ce qu'il
disait comme j'étais dans la pub à
l'époque max disait la monarchie la plus
blanc c'était l'argument pour me
descendre à mais j'ai utilisé les
billets étaient tout à fait pertinente
mais sont r donc la monarchie de la pub
lancé moi je lui racontais qu'en italie
le filet rendait s'appelait le filet
robespierre en souvenir de ce qu'on
avait fait un louis saez est alors
c'était comme ça c'était et j'avais avec
moi coup de chaud riach ligurie chaunu
est venu à mon secours et ça a été que
c'est extraordinaire parce que moi après
j'ai envoyé chaunu contre galop et voilà
et mais c'est la seule foi d'
apostrophes si ce qui veut dire que
thierry était quand même quelqu'un qui
connaissait le sens des médias puisque
c'est la seule fois je crois apostrophe
où je suis allé assez souvent ou la
salle a applaudi
thierry ardisson donc il avait fait la
salle c'est toujours ce que j'ai pensé
en tout cas c'est pas moi qui ai fait la
salle solidairement oui enfin quelqu'un
avec
coty rien dit sauf ce qui était tout à
fait surprenant par les
applaudissements
bon moi je ne voyais pas et je ne
comprends pas c'est un point d'histoire
max comment peux tu défendes robespierre
du fonds par on respire j'essaye
simplement de lui c'est important ça
j'essaye de le comprendre le seul livre
que j'ai écrit sur vieira compris tu l'a
accompagné sur robespierre je vais vous
citer la phrase de jaurès que je fais
mienne dans son histoire de la
révolution française qui est qui est
très dur pour la description du
personnage et je crois qu'à hamadé a
raison parce que c'est un personnage non
seulement chafouin physiquement mais
mais en même temps
rancunier bref c'est pas un personnage
épanouie ouvert son personnage fermes et
précis rétrécit et c'est ça fait aucun
doute et qui dit pourtant ceux-ci et
jaurès conclure en disant mais comme
l'histoire est choix c'est finalement à
côté de robespierre que j'irai m'asseoir
aux jacobins donc c'est vous dire voilà
lui mais le personnage et est évidemment
le contraire d'un personnage sympathique
ou de personnages ouvert il paraît
qu'elle est mort vierge c'est vrai on ne
connaît aucune espèce dans une aventure
il ya bien des gens qui se cachent pas
mal ça explique beaucoup de choses va
lui c'est très laid mais si oui oui ça
expliquerait mauguio un pur
extraordinaire à propos de robespierre
et qu on sait en général mais c'est que
il était élève du lycée du collège saint
louis rue saint jacques sur
l'emplacement aujourd'hui du lycée louis
le grand et le jour de l'entrée
officielle à paris après leur mariage à
leur arrivée de louis saez et marie
antoinette il pleuvait à verse et comme
il était le meilleur élève du collège
louis de grandval oui oui les migrants
c'est lui qui sous la pluie à lui le
compliment alors arrêt dans paris louis
saez et marie-antoinette ce qui est
extraordinaire comme rapprochement
historique c'est quelque chose dans
l'histoire c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable
c'est par exemple le comte léon le comte
léon c'était le fils de naples quand
napoléon a vu qu'ils pouvaient pas avoir
d'enfant
avec joséphine il a cru que c'était lui
la crise était de sa faute et à ce
moment là on à sa soeur lui a fait
rencontrer une une femme de chambre à l
well hopitalisés la soeur napoléon et il
a fait un enfant à cette femme donc il a
eu la preuve qu'ils pouvaient avoir des
enfants et le comte léon qui est un de
mes personnages favoris dans l'histoire
à passer tout le 19e siècle qui
ressemble comme une goutte d'eau à
napoléon bonaparte c'est vraiment le le
sosie parfait napoléon le vrai je sais
que votre ancêtre justement attend qu'un
conte leon à la fin de sa vie sur les
grands boulevards dans des bistrots
pourri en lui disait il ressent les
allées mais la main comme ça et on lui
donnait deux sous pour faire ma peau les
montois la d2 et de quelle manière vous
vous êtes les descendants du comte léon
commente aujourd'hui qu'il n'y avait pas
de l'hypnose du quand leonardo ne nous
descendit de de la peau des symboles et
en est redescendue ne sont pas alors je
reçois général jim généalogie magazine
absolue alors je regarde et je
m'aperçois avec stupeur que par ma mère
nous descendons ont le droit par l'impôt
joe di borgo qui était en 15 175 qui a
eu deux enfants mais à un garçon une
fille et moi je descends par ma mère de
deux garçons et napoléon sont les deux
pays
donc nous sommes cousins donc
j'ai un cadeau parce que pozzo di borgo
a été fait du crossmed
tu sais que dans le restaurant où il
voit tout le temps était bien à saint
germain le patron du restaurant a pris
un tableau d'une bataille de napoléon et
d'enlever la fed rappelons il a eu la
tête de mon grand père
il est épatant d'ailleurs ce restaurant
le monte vers des
secteurs ne fait une famille de
mégalomanie
napoléon votre douce à
une gravure de cuir et une gravure tu
sais j'ai en face de la maison se
livrèrent tchéquie mitterrand passé
c'est vrai mais le draveur avis car mon
niqab et la burqa à tous
alegre mais enfin ça toi fils aîné
max vous êtes sur quoi en ce moment là
après de gaulle napoléon au pyromane on
travaille sur les programmes intéresse
beaucoup elle s'intéresse enfin
m'intéresse beaucoup je fais une série
de cinq volumes sur l'empiré romain
roman et histoires autour de l'ampleur à
partir de documents à partir de
spartacus comment ça va se voir taxer la
république de la république pour toi je
simplifie un mail empire romain c'est un
truc tellement extraordinaire il ya une
formule qui m'est venu comme ça à
l'écrit lancé c'est le moment de
l'histoire où on tue sans remords avant
christianisme ont pu s'en remet en jette
les enfants mâles meurent sans crainte
en même temps réel ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir comment on est passé
précisément de 7,2 ce moment de
l'histoire où on tue sans remords au
moment où on tue avec remords mais au
milieu ya le christianisme et la vienne
le baroudeur chance elle qui a fait l'un
d'eux elle après la baie d'halong
le monde est inquiet et les gonzesses à
ça c'était sublime la rue
sainte-catherine exemple à s'auto rue
cardinal et qu'on veut on aller dans les
fumeries d'opium
vas y si j'ai castle d'ailleurs le soir
c'était des métis d'anglais et chinoises
tout ce qu'il y a de plus beau mais
c'était à tel point qu'on avait
scrupules à se laisser servir par l on
aurait voulu laisser le
gérant grand dressa également au brésil
à bahia à ça alors de bayard tu
t'aperçois que j'en sais il a fait le
tour de tout les noms mais vu les filles
avec ce long cours qui sont des
descendants d'esclaves mais elles sont
tellement sublime de vanczak avant tout
je veux dire que la semaine dernière
j'étais au kazakhstan et j'ai rencontré
au kazakhstan défi peut-être parmi les
plus belles que jamais alors mélange de
russes et chinois
à la fois quelque chose de la blondeur
et de la minceur russe attrait et de la
chinoise de haute taille et manifs
chocottes que c'est en éclats une bonne
nuit en pratique et des bouquins sur la
tolérance
dis moi j'ai vu ton dictionnaire de la
pornographie c'est pas le mien
même moi alors je vais te dire même moi
j'étais choqué il ya un article sur le
fist fucking oui on est de traduire ce
fait sa mort ce n'est pas moi qui les
critiquent
attention c'est un livre extrêmement
salée que tu préface que je préfère j'ai
fait trois antique de dents dont
l'article bunuel qui serait d'ailleurs
extrêmement surpris de se voir dans un
dictionnaire de pornographie c'est ce
que je lis dedans et puis la préface
mois d'arrêt ah non ça n'a rien à voir
financé avec votre élection celui là il
y en a quelques-uns oui mais c'est une
somme je crois aussi en plus très
intéressant
il ya quelques articles plus
intéressants via gang bang
bang bang va j'entendais parler d'entrée
du palais
expliqué
pornographie en jeu ça veut dire pour
nous c'est le ceux qui écrivent sur les
prostituées encore non c'est sa part
noté ça c'est devenu tout à fait autre
chose c'est de plus le skillshot que
ceux qui ont su ce que ce qui est
grossier vulgaire ceux de quoi on parle
pas et ne pas parler de ce qu'on ne
parle pas est très intéressant parce
qu'il ya énormément de renseignements il
n'y a pas que identique sur le marquis
de sade
cuisine beaucoup de choses très bien
sociologie android et monographies chez
lui cela tient aussi à bas
prix en double moi le fils flynn y est
aussi allé dans ma vie
voilà pourriez parler français ben je te
dire tu veux je lise oui le début que ce
prix consiste en l'introduction d'une
main entière voire de l'avant bras dans
le rectum ou pas acceptation récente
dans le vagin bon c'est nico visionner
les crues
sont les coulisses les
deux langues les gangs et de
l'interjection bang imite le bruit d'une
déflagration le mot gang bang
originalement réservé pour parler d'un
viol collectif
désigne aujourd'hui un acte sexuel
volontaire avec un nombre indéterminé de
partenaires et plus généralement la
pratique d'une relation sexuelle d'une
femme avec plusieurs hommes c'est la
phrase suivante que je trouve
intéressante quand il s'agit d'un homme
avec plusieurs femmes
on parle plutôt de rivas gagne ben je
savais tu vois là tu veux que je te dise
quelque chose tu l'as lu avec
gourmandise bien sûr d'avoir je suis un
très bon lecteur tu sais que la
championne du monde donc bon gars c'est
à 1,720 partenaires en même temps non
non après l'autre
c'est là dedans c'est dans ce
dictionnaire est au passage à l'an 2000
a mis une hardeuse américaine avait fait
le pari de te faire un gang bang avec
deux mille hommes dans la journée
j'en ai dans la journée la nuit disons
entraînée par yves n est pas comme quoi
les le record c'est impossible mais
c'est ouais c'est ça fait combien de
minutes par partie c'est sur la foi dont
celui vous avez vous avez eu des travaux
pratiques ou pas
il faut tout étudier
suis tout à fait non je suis quand même
tout à fait effrayer sous la direction
de philippe ii di falco s'est pas du
tout c'est le mari de mme enseignants
il fallait que les confesseurs que ce
répondre à toutes les questions que leur
poser les sélectionnés ce qu'on fait
c'est des pêcheurs qui on a fait à
partir de la fin du xvième siècle des
manuels pour les confesseurs le plus
grand auteur est un jésuite espagnol
s'appelait sanchez qui a passé toute sa
vie le malheureux assis sur des bancs de
marbre cas ça va chauffer beaucoup
changé dans les grandes aires changer de
bord grâce était très chaud à écrire sur
tous les cas possibles depuis at on
parlé après on avait vu présenter des
cas est même il ya eu des canulars en
inventer des choses qu'on allait
présenter comme vrai auquel il répondait
il analysé qui comité extraordinaire
c'était et non c'était mal c'était après
être il ne pouvait pas mais il a dû tout
prévoir avec des animaux avec des
végétaux avec nous tous qui était oui il
y avait à l'époque on disait qu'il y
avait dans l'île de formose des gens
c'était une légende qui avait une queue
au bas de la colonne vertébrale une
petite queue comme les singes et on lui
a raconté que on avait amené un de ses
hommes à queue à la cour de versailles
qu'on l'aurait placé entre deux femmes
et qui s'était servi de ces deux arbres
avec les développer l'une d'elle ayant
tu as tout or ici développé qu'elle
n'avait pu la pénétrer lui alors on lui
a demandé de trancher et de dire qu'est
ce que vous donnez comme pénitence dans
ce cas là qui est merveilleux cette
immensité de la rue qu'est ce que je
faisais c'était un canular d'étudiants
là que deux alors il a distingué je me
rappelle plus assez mais je crois qu'il
a dit que bon dans un grain cas il y
avait sodomie amène à la raison dit par
des
sodomies incomplète dans ses fins
c'est à dire qu'avec la queue on ne peut
pas déjà culte et pas dans l'autre cas
fornication simple
mais comme tu es devenu un spécialiste
jean claude on peut dire aujourd'hui
quand il a été inventé toujours les
canons regarde regarde et encore de quoi
un office faculté encore avant les
centres le film fut un
temps le fisc n'a ni en rien de nouveau
là-dedans puisqu'on paquet récent c'est
qu'on lui a donné un nom taille est de
nouveau tombé à raison ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on est baptisé le
fils de qui c'est pas qu'on les
pratiques et j'imagine cette pratique
depuis mais je crois que robben
s'avérait sentir et je crois que l'
usage sexuelle des bébés qui est une des
horreurs nous avons mis l'art de notre
temps et nouveau j'ai cherché partout je
n'ai rien trouvé sauf sauf dans une
planche des caprices de goya moi je
crois que c'était celle qui se fait
justement sur scène c'est la planche 69
exactement des on voit un homme
pratiquer une fellation sur ce qui a
l'air d'être un bébé on est dans la
collision d'un goya 69 des caprices mais
c'est tout ce que j'ai trouvé ni dans
les hauteurs orientaux ni dans pétrole
ni danse vénale je n'ai rien trouvé sur
la pédophilie pour sade par exemple
commencent à 7 8 ans mais on voit dans
les informations des faits divers ou des
bébé de 15 mois sont utilisés à des fins
sexuelles aujourd'hui vendu échanger ses
démons alors sérieuse qui se passe
ça parce que voilà le en fait si tu veux
quand tu fais un dîner avec des français
il ya toujours un moment où on parle de
rezé qui a dénoncé jean moulin
quand même tu vas c'est très français si
je peux sentir à nous et c'est notre
problème à nous qui a dénoncé jean
moulin alors je peux pas porter seuls le
jura gens se disent il ya prescription
ils apprenaient
écoutant la tension qui va vous répondre
alors bon j'ai été ami avec hardy j'ai
été ami avec bénouville bénouville
croyait que hardy avait été arrêté mais
qu'il n'avait pas été maintenue donc il
l'avait gardé dans son réseau or si
hardy avait dit qu'il avait passé un
mois en prison il au il était cet
automne au billet vert elle était grillé
ne devait pas faire partie d'un réseau
qui a des lois jean moulin alors attends
je peux dire la vérité c'est que les
allemands ayant arrêté a redit le
suivait et sachant que il faisait partie
des résistances ada qui le suivait ils
ont suivi a redit à gagnières à caluire
et on te fait le coup donc en fait
personne n'a dénoncé jean moulin ce sont
les allemands qui ont suivi a redit que
s'est fait piéger et ont ras la vérité
ce sont les allemands qui ont dénoncé
jean moulin je peux vous dire que c'est
chez moi que ça s'est passé ou
bénouville appris que que hardy avait
été non pas à venelles n'était pas parti
tout de suite mais avec la cellule en
prison c'est là qu'il a engueulé il ya
eu il ya eu chez moi une engueulade
absolument terrible bénouville et hardy
parce que là on nous a pas dit qu'ils
avaient été prises oui mais je pouvais
pas te dire parce que vous avez été
prisonnière et il entend ça s'est passé
chez moi les injures et puis après tu
craches
c'est en
ça vous fait quoi faute non vous
appartiennent plus que vous allez au
début c'était quand même ça me
choquerait pas ce qu'il y avait de
l'hélico musée ouais voilà il doit y
avoir des villes général j'aime pas
alors je veux mais voilà c'est comme ça
le reste je dois accepter le changement
pas aujourd'hui pour les femmes
aujourd'hui pour les français la france
et patrice laffont ah oui absolument
quand je sors avec lui c'est lui c'est
lui la star quand je vois quand j'allais
au foot avec lui vous dis je voyais
j'étais avec lui comme sa pirogue puis
je voyais les gens qui se retourne un
but à zéro alors patrice leconte est bon
mais
tu nous racontes pathé tournée patrice
fait une tournée l'avantagent du tour de
règles auxquelles je te sens tu sais que
tu fais énormément de date contrairement
aux tournées de gens célèbres qui font
30 40 bateaux qui jouent de moins au
même endroit moi j'en fais 150 mais dans
un endroit où qui s'ouvre totalement
venons donc j'ai pris ni à moi et à mes
plus beaux souvenirs c'est une petite
ville près de sedan on arrive à jour en
novembre jean tu vois un peu déjà froid
et tout et on voit une petite salle des
bancs en bois et un poil achetant un
poêle à bois donc on dit alors c'est
super la scène
qui jusqu'à l'est de toi à jean-claude
en gros enfin j'exagère vu un max tiens
bon c'est difficile et où ils disent
étonnés de son
bain il n'y en a pas dans les coulisses
ah bon non elles sont dans la salle j
attend dé moi pas comprendre la pièce
sur l'ambition a pas descendre dans la
salle dire aux gens aux c'est noël
est il très tôt qu'il y avait un acteur
qui chante le glaciologue ans qui buvait
beaucoup et donc ils urinaient
énormément et je dis aux mecs en
déconnant parce qu'il était pas question
de s'en aller je lui dis bah on va
ensemble on va partir donc puisqu'on
peut pas jouer au patois la team gym ou
si vous vous rendez pas compte pour lui
c'était tu vois et je dis mais je
trouver une solution je fais vite et il
arrive avec beaucoup discuté avec un
seau en plastique vert donc je me
souviendrai très longtemps et pendant la
pièce mon camarade massoulier qui était
qui buvait énormément dans la pièce donc
il y avait très envie d'uriner uriné
dans le seau en coulisses mais comme les
coulisses était exactement à 2 m en
entendant du tout qu'on l'entendait plus
mais mieux
j mais comment vous faites avec les
acteurs jamie dimon oui on a eu quand on
s'appelait cette magnifique actrice qui
a joué dans la boule cette vieille dame
qui était allé jouer sur la fin de sa
vie une pièce je me rappelle pas
laquelle et donc est exactement mêmes
conditions que nous qu'elle n'a pas fait
de scandale du retour elle a dit de les
moines bouteilles de lait moins de
bouteilles d'eau minérale la coupe et il
paraît qu royal dansent derrière son
paravent l a fait dans sa bouteille
minérales succédé un truc là si j'étais
éditeur je demande je te demanderai de
raconter ce genre d'histoire et je
dirais patrice laffont de la télévision
vous raconte vrigne aux bois et ça
marcherait
j'en demande pardon à ta femme mais il
karim de rêver un cinquième mariage
n'auront pas du tout
excuse moi une bonne question parce que
tu sais quoi jane fonda m'a dit l'autre
jour en fait la question qu'est-ce qui
les renards
nous raconter partout avec vadim et où
incroyable elle a 68 ans et elle dit en
fait je me demande si je vais être à
nouveau amoureuse vous l'avez connu à
quel âge hélène sur terrain c'était en
quatre vingt deux ça fait combien 23 3
ans quand vous aviez 88man 23
65 ans à ton âge donc vous avez
rencontré vert mais vous êtes tombé
amoureux
c'est bien ça mon chéri coûts et
d'accélérer nôtre ne prend pas exemple
sur ton grand-père là c'est parce que
moi je me suis toujours dans la position
de ce clavier qu'on va quitter pour la
jeune
sam élite pour la polygamie parce qu'en
fait dans les sociétés polygame on
aurait pu dit pas sa femme trop page et
on en épouser une autre mon gars sa
femme
très heureuse non plus c'est à dire que
l'ajustement il ya des trouve que c'est
mieux d'être répudiée avec trois gosses
et se retrouve à la rue moi je préfère
la polygamie c'est plus est plus radical
je crois c'est pour se reconstruire et
la polygamie quatre femmes et un mari
les 4 500 tentes voilà
on est assez d'accord non non mais c'est
vrai
qu'on a vécu ça mais on a regardé
ses beaux musées les femmes
le grand robert
est trop gentil puis avec eux toute ma
famille comme ça et mes amis que j'aime
alors là
c'est moi c'est une soirée formidable je
suis ravi
son millefeuille
moi je dis que je suis un millefeuille
parce que j'ai eu cette série se
justifie pas je n'oublie pas mes
expériences précédentes je le devais je
ne fais pas ça ça fait une série de
couches et qui toutes participent à
l'ensemble et ressemble c'est ma vie
j'en suis à mon quatrième art et 4e et
5e
je ne savais pas ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est pour ça je me permettait de poser
cette question appelle silva dans le moi
j'en suis apte à trois femmes des ans de
mariage et un pareil mais alors si je
compte les faux mariage ce serait
inconnu
je suis un enfant de choeur par rapport
à leur apport robert laffont
la formule de monogame séquentiel et
décisive c'est une morale de vie d'une
chose importe thierry que veut savoir
que mon jean claude carrière a connu sa
deuxième femme non comment
elle avait connu d'autres hommes avant
moi et elle était un soir avec un de ces
hommes
couchés il s'approchait tendrement
d'elle non quand nous a paru mal la
télévision jacques chancel et moi et il
m'a été racontée par aidés par lui que
je te qu elle a repoussé cette offre
excuse moi c'est celui d'art des
noms ça peut maryse di s'est fâchée elle
a regardé jean-claude pas mort mais
c'est comme ça tout a commencé quand la
deuxième femme avait connu des hommes
avant de toi et vous vous êtes mariés
vierge la première fois ta première fois
oui incroyable tu viens fait croire que
j'avais 22 ans la deuxième foire à tout
avec un temps encore quatre ou cinq
livres et nous saurons tout de toi
c'est vrai c'est bien
le pion
[Musique]
nous
non
on
[Musique]
vous
oui
[Musique]
salon
c'est bien mais on est bien alors je
passe mes bien aimés tronquée
il ya un truc quand même dans votre
livre il ya quand même un truc est à la
fois très beau et très triste oui mais
ça c'est la mort ça c'est là c'est la
mort d'un enfant ça c'est une expérience
que je ne savais pas ce que c'était et
personne ne sait ce que c'est tant qu'on
n'a pas subi cette série de survivre à
ces enfants c'est quelque chose de
qu'une chose
le jour de l'enterrement vous prenez le
bouquin il ya la dédicace à toi mon papa
je rentre chez moi j'avais vraiment
angoissé perdu je me dis il faudrait que
je trouve un livre qui me qui m'apaise
parce que je crois toujours à vous
pouvoir la lecture et je regarde ma
bibliothèque c'est énorme il ya
plusieurs milliers de livres et et je
regarde je regarde rien ne me tente et
puis je prends un livre au hasard au
hasard sur donc des milliers de l'audace
de villé et et
je touche et puis j'ouvre et je vois
pour toi petit papa ce livre qui te dira
mieux que moi la vie et la mort au
chocolat signal wifi alors que je sais
c'est pas possible six états et
étrangement c'est s'avouer j'étais comme
ça et qu'il n'a sage de l'au delà mais
tu ne peux pas
en tout cas robert moi je peux te dire
une chose c'est que quand tu seras vieux
cas pas de souci à se faire avec toute
la famille que j'ai autour de la boire
tous les jours qu'on va s'occuper de
poney
quand tu ça dans ton grand âge là en
attendant continue à travailler
[Applaudissements]
attention on termine sur un petit
intermède musical
[Musique]
nous non
est ce toi
la loi 86 des pigeons notre toit
c'est à force de fréquenter rhodia
ça arrange personne
elle se doit chez release on joue trois
fois heureux
le béni soit le sien
10 euros de mise
moi ni de benjamin
comme moi descendu
vu de mes premiers sont là company has
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dire maintenant je ne sais pas
jouer
c'était sympa c'était très simple il y
avait une ambiance on il est très gentil
finalement il est tendre il est et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux